are there any obstacles barriers that
you are finding yourself run into that
maybe you didn't expect it's the
infrastructure is the challenge
realistically if you can get people that
are effective managers that you can
trust you can delegate to and you have
them time after time you can escalate it
and the senior manager on that team
that's how you get them to be able to be
a hands-off director so yes their
Hands-On billing managers now but the
Viewpoint and the structure is when you
end up getting to this their role moves
more to people management me I then move
back to more to a macro level open up
other offices or whatever theoretically
I don't even need to be involved in that
manages itself and grows itself because
you have that infrastructure but the
main challenge getting that core
infrastructure because it is hard